una imagen vista en todo el mundo miles
de personas intentaban huir de kabul y
del avance de los talibanes 24 horas
antes la ciudad había sido tomada el
presidente ganó y hoy se anunció un
gobierno interino dirigido por los
talibanes sólo seis semanas antes a 60
kilómetros de kabul en el aeródromo de
bagram miles de tropas estadounidenses
abandonaron la base en la noche que los
afganos van a tener que ser capaces de
hacerlo ellos mismos con la fuerza aérea
que tienen bagram que en su día fue la
mayor base estadounidense del país con
10.000 soldados se convirtió de repente
en una ciudad fantasma muchos temían que
la retirada masiva fuera un catalizador
para el rápido avance de los talibanes
temores que se demostraron correctos los
talibanes entraron en la segunda ciudad
de afganistán kandahar el 9 de julio y
19 días después hicieron lo mismo en la
tercera del país eran funcionarios
estadounidenses advirtieron de que kabul
podría ser tomada en 90 días aunque el
presidente gun y se mantuvo desafiante
es una necesidad obvia tener seguridad
nacional junto con la policía y las
fuerzas nacionales orientado al
ministerio de defensa para que asuma la
plena responsabilidad de la seguridad de
todos los residentes
kabul cayó antes de lo esperado el 15 de
agosto los talibanes entraron con poca
resistencia el presidente gane yo y el
segundo reino de los talibanes comenzó
hasta
quiero felicitar al pueblo musulmán
afgano por esta enorme victoria
especialmente a los ciudadanos y
residentes de kabul
la batalla no había terminado para los
que intentaban abandonar el país el
aeropuerto de kabul se vio desbordado
por los desesperados por escapar la
situación dio lugar a uno de los mayores
traslados aéreos de la historia sobre
eeuu evacuó a más de 80.000 personas
durante 11 días pero para los que no
tuvieron la suerte de salir la vida bajo
los talibanes se convirtió en una nueva
realidad